[Música]
[Aplausos]
vamos a hacer un pequeño experimento con
todo porque les nervios a ver son si los
miro así en general veo que puedo decir
que hay hombres hay varones hay mujeres
veo diferentes edades puedo intuir que
quizás de diferentes profesiones
diferentes orígenes sé que hay gente
otras provincias así que bueno puedo
decir que estamos presentes en un grupo
diverso es lo que dice ahí y hay otras
cosas que nos une y hoy es puede
participar a esta experiencia de esa
diversidad hoy nos presenta acá entonces
también puedo pensar que hay más cosas
que nos unen
entonces déjenme hacerles una pregunta y
quiero que levanten la mano quienes de
ustedes utilizan la tecnología ya sean
en sus casas o en el trabajo levanta la
mano
juana son un montón entonces podemos
decir también que compartimos el uso de
la tecnología y podríamos intuir por lo
tanto que la tecnología también es
diverso
pero qué pasa si yo les digo que las
personas que crean tecnologías que nos
dan la capacidad de que estemos estoy
aquí transmitiendo por streaming que
ustedes se puedan comunicar que puedan
usar el celular estas personas que
eligen como la tecnología como fisio y
profesión o también otras profesiones
como la que se llaman ciencia tecnología
matemática o ingeniería lo que no sé
cómo estén las personas que eligen
trabajar en esas áreas
solamente aproximadamente el 30% son
mujeres
ahí vemos que no estamos hablando tanto
de diversidad nos está faltando un
poquito
pero me ponen decir bueno pero
ingeniería química hay montón de chicas
en ingeniería médica también hay un
montón pero qué pasa con las carreras
más duras por ahí con ingeniería
mecánica electrónica eléctrica y ahí
paso a contarles por un poco hacia el
ministerio personal y bueno como les
dijeron antes nací en tucumán estudié
ingeniería electrónica en la universidad
nacional de tucumán fue una elección
bastante fácil de un sentido porque me
gustaba mucho la física y la matemática
entonces me fijé que carreras tenía de
estas materias y con otra amiga
compañera en el crimen nos escribimos a
níger electrónica donde una comisión de
300 personas
éramos la únicas dos mujeres
transitamos nuestra carrera con bastante
dificultad porque también los docentes
no concebían que esas mujeres en este
ámbito en el norte del país ustedes
saben que las cosas por ahí en el
interior en general van un poco más
lentas y no se confía todavía en la
mujer dentro del ámbito tecnológico e
ingenieril
sin embargo con mucho esfuerzo y gracias
que me da el apoyo de muchos de mis
compañeros logré recibirme mi mejor
amiga no se pudo graduar y se me mete en
la cabeza que quería trabajar en la
industria y qué pasa de nuevo en el
norte argentino era muy difícil siendo
mujer insertarme la industria y allí me
empezar cuentas que pasaban ciertas
cosas hay un tema de estereotipos en
donde no se consigue a la mujer dentro
del ámbito de ingeniería y lo de la
ciencia de tecnología hay cuestiones más
asociadas al entorno había algunas fotos
mías trabajando luego que finalmente
tuve que emigrar de tucumán y buscarme
mi destino profesional en otros lugares
donde se concibe un entorno de equidad y
diversidad y bueno estuve trabajando en
bueno en neuquén a como nos aires en
otros países de latinoamérica pero sin
embargo había ese entorno incompatible
donde por ejemplo el mameluco estoy
estoy buscando en esa foto era de corte
de varón y eso hacía que me traigas
insegura porque ese babe luco tan grande
y sin cintura adecuado para el cuerpo de
un varón y no de una mujer no me dejaba
trabajar bien me resultaba incómodo e
inclusive ese exceso de tela se me podía
enganchar en algún elemento rotante y
causarle un accidente
entonces con eso más sumado que a veces
no había baños me llamó en una serie de
pautas de que el entorno en el que
estaba trabajando no estaba preparado
todavía para que una mujer trabaja en
ingeniería
y sumaba eso afortunadamente software
tras pasar todos estos escollos puedes
seguir adelante y trabajar y eso me
permite a trabajar en industria
alimenticia nuclear o inclusive en el
petróleo pero sumado a eso hay un montón
de factores que impiden que las mujeres
elijamos carreras técnicas y esto si lo
pensamos desde el origen a dónde está y
bueno hay una falta clarísima de
incentivo entre los niños porque en la
niñez es donde se desarrolla la vocación
y ahí es cuando tenemos que empezar a
pensar que si nos presentamos a los
chicos la oportunidad de que ellos
puedan soñar que pueden ser ingenieros o
pueden ser cocineros pueden ser médicos
pueden ser lo que ellos quieran y contar
nuestros con nuestro apoyo para poder
seguir adelante y conseguir sus sueños
no no va a pasar y los chicos te des la
gran ventaja de que son pequeñas
esponjas que absorben todos los que les
ponemos alrededor tienen ganas de
participar a nuevas experiencias y no
tienen esos prejuicios no tienen los
estereotipos de instaurados no tienen
estos estás lejos de géneros que
nosotros los adultos a medida que vamos
transitando por la vida
también siendo afectado manera por la
sociedad tenemos los chicos no lo tienen
de ahí nace lo que llevamos adelante con
el grupo de voluntarios
bueno
qué es el programa routing proteína es
una iniciativa en donde va
s
es una iniciativa en donde podemos mucho
corazón y mucho
y empujándose por eso mi emoción pero
bueno es la llevamos a cabo junto con un
increíble grupo de voluntarios de los
cuales varios están acá
en este tema gratuita abierta a donde
puedan participar chicos en particular
chicos que no tienen acceso
habitualmente a la tecnología si bien
hoy en día hay una hay un fuerte empuje
desde la secretaría de educación en que
en todas las escuelas se instalarían en
programas que para que los chicos tengan
acceso a aprender programación y
robótica no todos los chicos tienen
acceso a esas escuelas a donde toda la
infraestructura está preparada y los
docentes están preparados entonces en
nuestro lugar con este equipo de
voluntarios lo que tratamos de hacer es
transmitir a los chicos los primeros
conceptos desde la física la ingeniería
como armar un circuito como circula la
electricidad que es la energía y luego
de a poquito vamos introduciendo
conceptos sobre programación pensamiento
lógico y finalmente pueden programar a
través de una computadora un robot de la
firma el ego que tiene la división de
educación que justamente se utiliza para
poder introducir conceptos de ingeniería
electrónica y programación en la escuela
puesto como les decía 6 gratuito está
abierto a la comunidad la idea es que
podemos llegar a la mayor cantidad de
chicos posibles para poder darles una
oportunidad y no empujarlos a que sean
todos ingenieros pero si a despertar el
bichito de la curiosidad y ver cómo
funcionan las cosas que están en su
entorno que ya tengan esa curiosidad de
saber cómo funciona el mundo
los chicos trabajan en equipos mixtos
semana presentó chicas segundo por
ciento chicos también un poco para
desmitificar este tema de que la
tecnología tiene género sí y para que se
sientan cómodos trabajando en diversidad
porque hay muchas iniciativas que quizás
para un nuevo mano vamos a empoderar a
todas las chicas que trabajan en
tecnología y está buenísimo pero si
trabajamos juntos todos en un ambiente
diverso
vamos a tratar de estimular esa ese
futuro profesional donde van a tener que
compartir en un ambiente que hoy por ahí
lamentablemente está mayormente habitado
por hombres desde ese lugar los chicos
trabajan en equipos con un instructor a
cargo que les va guiando a través de los
diferentes desafíos que van cumpliendo y
luego participan en desafíos grupales a
donde todos aportando sus capacidades
sus ideas tienen que cumplir un proyecto
grupal
también trabajamos con los padres y esto
es muy importante porque los papás son
quienes inscriben a los chicos y los
papás muchas veces no saben que un grupo
o una iniciativa de robótica y
tecnología gratuita puede ser también
para las nenas nos pasó les cuento una
anécdota que en las inscripciones un
poco este porcentaje se guardan que les
conté el principio del 30% de mujeres
trabajando en este en bueno cuando sobra
sin concesiones abiertas los papás que
son los que inscriben a los chicos
efectivamente vemos que inscriben
mayormente a sus hijos varones por
ejemplo de 100 niños inscriptos
solamente un 30% son nenas sociales
mismos números se van repitiendo
entonces hay un tema de que el sesgo de
género lo tenemos nosotros los adultos
para ello también empezamos a hacer
estos planes de acompañamiento a los
papás para que desde casa con
herramientas gratuitas que están
accesibles de internet puedan acompañar
el aprendizaje de sus hijos y por qué no
incentivar a que hermanitos primos y
compañeros se inmersa en este hermoso
mundo de tecnologías
pero también nosotros los ingenieros
como bastante cuadrados somos y creo que
juntos acaban de entender porque
estábamos pensando que estábamos
enseñando tecnología estábamos enseñando
robótica ingeniería cosas así muy
pomposas y muy copados por eso pero qué
pasó nos dimos cuenta que no solamente
estamos enseñando cuestiones técnicas a
los chicos también les enseñamos acerca
de diversidad de liderazgo el trabajo en
equipo y hacer proyectos en conjunto de
que tengan fe en sí mismos y por qué no
ser agentes de cambio
y termino haciendo como una excusa un
disfrute entre alumnos docentes padres
en donde tratamos de transmitirle la
ingeniería la tecnología como una
herramienta de cambio
eso no se puede hacer de uno solo
pero este es el equipo que está detrás
de todo esto y también pueden ver que es
un equipo diverso que vienen de
diferentes universidades son chicos y
chicas que mayormente estudian o
trabajan en ingeniería y tecnología pero
también nos dimos cuenta que si
necesitábamos en los chicos
transmitirles conceptos más allá de
tecnología nos hacía falta ayuda y está
bueno pero las horas
entonces levantamos la mano y
contactamos con gente que se dedica a
temas de pedagogía y enseñanza para que
nos hagan un complemento mayor y podamos
seguir con este proyecto venimos
trabajando hace cuatro años saben de
iniciativas de este tipo y la verdad que
sí cuanto más el último año
aproximadamente mil personas personas
por nuestros talleres encontrando los
chicos de sus papás y docentes y vi
personas que asisten a nuestras charlas
y es un orgullo para nosotros poder
seguir creciendo en ese lugar
ahora no estamos solos afortunadamente
acá hay voluntarios de toda
latinoamérica que pertenecen a la misma
organización en la cual está enmarcado
nuestro proyecto
cada uno de ellos tienen diferentes
iniciativas locales para promover el uso
de tecnología como una herramienta
social
y si ven este tipo de acercamiento a
tecnologías más chicos no solamente
sucede acá en argentina sino que tenemos
ejemplos en relación
amigos que están haciendo mismo proyecto
similar en honduras del cual nosotros
nos inspiramos lo adornamos le dimos una
impronta local propia argentina y lo
trajimos y también en paraguay en su
grupo más joven que está empezando
recién con estas iniciativas y de alguna
manera se están apoyando inspirando a
nuestro trabajo
no me queda más mucho más que decir que
este tema de poder devolverle a la
comunidad nosotros como profesionales
que tuvimos la oportunidad de estudiar
que nuestras familias nos apoyen que
que la sociedad nos dé un lugar
pero
verdad
estoy usando universidad pública y
bañarse como esta casa siento que le
debo de alguna manera devolverle a mi
comunidad de manera que eso pueda
pensando una docente una doctora que es
parte de la organización que nos vía nos
dijo hay mucha gente que se dedica a
hacer voluntariado en comedores o en
hospitales y eso está buenísimo pero
ustedes tienen más conocimientos con
saben sobre tecnologías y saben sobre
tecnología llevada a proyectos sociales
y brindar eso devolverles a la comunidad
tiene un valor enorme y creo que todos
los que compartimos este equipo lo
sabemos y así los llevamos a cabo desde
ese lugar yo creo que todos con nuestras
capacidades con nuestra disponibilidad
podemos devolver a la comunidad y
siempre pensando que buscamos un mundo
más equitativo con mayor calidad de
oportunidades para todos para construir
un mundo mejor podemos hacer una
diferencia entonces yo les dejo una
invitación así como este grupo puede
existir gracias al aporte de voluntades
de gente que se suma que tiene ganas de
otorgar su tiempo y sus capacidades los
invito a ustedes que desde su lugar
puedan también aportar un granito de
arena para hacer este mundo mejor
[Aplausos]
[Música]